le tourisme dit du haut de gamme ne se
porte pas bien ni de force
c'est une tendance qui se confirme hélas
au milieu de l'été et au moment où les
premiers chiffres nous parviennent après
un nouveau trimestre d'études
statistiques
en revanche un créneau intéressant dans
ce tourisme très confortable et qui lui
a l'air de bien marcher c'est celui des
relais et châteaux le succès de cette
formule relativement nouvelle tient
peut-être dans un pari difficile pour
l'hôtelier qui vous reçoit chez lui dans
un cadre souvent très cossu mais qui
tient quand même à offrir des prix
accessibles en général deux sens en 230
à 300 francs en moyenne pour un menu de
qualité
un reportage de xavier robert
pour les 115 hôtel quatre étoiles ou 4
étoiles luxe de la région les temps
deviennent difficiles d'abord depuis
octobre 80 la tva sur ce total ries est
passé en deux temps de 7 à 18,6 pour
cent
ensuite la taxation à 30% sur les frais
généraux a conduit beaucoup
d'entreprises à freiner sur les frais de
réception
quant à l'inflation à 14% elle a été
pour tout le monde
morosité donc du secteur d'autant plus
que le dollar à 7 francs n'a pas rétabli
la situation
là nous sommes un peu étonné ça va péter
parce qu'on pensait effectivement que le
dollar a cette fois elle nous amener
beaucoup de clients américains
alors nous apercevons que dans la
clientèle le global des hôtels sur les
étrangers je parle des étrangers nous
avons à peu près le même nombre
d'américains que l'année dernière il n'y
a pas d'augmentation pour l'instant des
clients américains
il ya une baisse des clients belges la
belgique ayant probablement des
problèmes économiques importants par
contre nous avons heureusement une
augmentation de clients de certains pays
en tête l'italie et l'angleterre
c'est ce qui compense un peu la baisse
de clientèle française et c'est un point
qui bien sûr est vite ce qui est une
crise trop grave dans l'hôtellerie à 45
km de paris jacques sourisseau marié
deux enfants et c'est en dépit des
vagues de maintenir le cap sur une
hôtellerie de haute qualité dans un
ancien relais de chasse à fontenay
trésigny loin de la route parce qu'il a
choisi la carte tranquillité il perd en
revanche des clients à cause d'un
règlement tatillon qui limitent à un
seul panneau sa publicité routière sa
table est réputé mais le seul bouche à
oreille ne suffirait pas alors il a
adhéré à la chaîne des relais et
châteaux et comme les 300 adhérents de
l'association
il profite d'une promotion collective en
france et à l'étranger d'un système de
réservation et d'une centrale d'achat
avantage appréciable mais le combier
reconnaît que tu dis parfois sur sa
trésorerie
côté contrainte ça nous oblige
évidemment à voir
un personnel
nombreux certains jours le personnel et
plus nombreux que les que les clients
est ce que la formule de cette
hôtellerie et viable tout lundi non non
dans le cas particulier dans ma maison
je travaille beaucoup plus les week-ends
déjà que le milieu de semaine est
évidemment beaucoup plus au printemps et
en automne j'ai un hiver difficile qui
m'oblige la ferme et de moi j'envisage
de fermer peut-être un petit peu plus
longtemps à prendre un caractère
saisonnier parce que charges sont très
lourdes en hiver et la clientèle plus
restreindre les parisiens viennent quand
il fait beau note cet hôtelier qui par
ailleurs reçoit pendant l'année pas mal
de séminaires comme ici les
représentants d'une multinationale venu
se mettre au vert pendant deux jours
mais la taxation à 30% sur les frais
généraux va à coup sûr ralentir cette
activité alors pour échapper à la tva
18,6 pour cent sept ateliers qu'on va
bien sûr se faire déclasser en 3 étoiles
mais ce sera difficile aurait faire
marche arrière quand on a le plaisir
d'exploiter faire en 4 étoiles c'est des
fois difficile et y parvenir il est
regrettable de faire marche arrière et
de votre grade et je m'y oppose et
j'essaierai de tenir le plus longtemps
possible et en maintenant les
prestations
je veux maintenant je ne devrais pas de
descendre dans la qualité du service que
j'offre à mes clients un couple de
touristes américains a appris
l'existence de cet hôtel dans un bureau
de l'office de tourisme français de new
york ils sont enchantés de leur séjour
quant à jacques sourisseau leur route
s'il ne perd pas d'argent il n'en gagne
pas non plus avant il tenait à trois
étoiles près des tueries qui marchait
très bien il a choisi pour le plaisir de
s'installer à la campagne
il risque un jour étranglés par les
taxes de devoir fermer boutique